are you worried about variants so
looking out into the future are you
what's your vision for
all the possible trajectories that this
virus takes in human society i'm totally
worried about the variants
delta was
such an impressive arrival on the scene
in all the wrong ways i mean it took
over
the world yeah in the space of just a
couple months because of its extremely
contagious ability viruses would be
beautiful if they weren't terrifying
yeah exactly i mean this whole story of
viral evolution scientifically is just
amazingly elegant anybody who really
wanted to understand how evolution works
in real time
study sars cov2
because it's not just delta it's alpha
and it's beta and it's gamma and it's
the fact that these sweep through
uh the world's population
by
fairly minor differences in fitness
so the real question many people are
wrestling is is delta it it is it is it
such a fit virus that nothing else will
be able to displace it
i don't know
i mean there's now delta ay4
which is a variant of delta that at
least in the uk
seems to be taking over
the delta population as though it's
maybe even a little more contagious that
might be the first hint that we're
seeing something new here it's not a
completely different virus it's still
delta but it's delta plus
you know the big worry lex is
what's out there that is so different
that the vaccine protection doesn't work
and we don't know how different it needs
to be for the vaccine to stop working
that's the that's the terrifying thing
about each of these variants
it's like uh it's always a pleasant
surprise the vaccine seems to have still
have efficacy
and hooray for our immune system may i
say
because the vaccine immunized you
against that original wuhan virus
now we can see
that especially after two doses and even
more so after a booster your immune
system is so clever that it's also
making a diversity of antibodies to
cover some other things that might
happen to that virus to make it a little
different
and you're still getting really good
coverage
even for beta which was
south africa b1351 which is the most
different
it looks pretty good
but that doesn't mean it will always be
as good as that if something gets really
far away from the original virus now the
good news is we would know what to do in
that situation
the mrna vaccines allow you
to redesign the vaccine like that
and to quickly get it through a few
thousand participants in a clinical
trial to be sure it's raising antibodies
and then bang you could go
but i don't want to have to do that
there will be people's lives at risk in
the meantime and what's the best way to
keep that from happening well don't
quite try to cut down the number of
infections
because you don't get variance unless
the virus is replicating in a person
you